hi Erica my name's Andrew and I'm going
to try and answer your question what's
your vision for the rest of your life
well just a cue better let me tell you
something about what really motivates me
I have a couple of kids and I realized
not so long ago that's when those kids
are my age they're potentially going to
be living in a world which is in crisis
there's not going to be enough water not
enough energy not enough food to go
around and so that really has made me
think what could we do about this happy
to change you though and my area of
specialty is looking at you health risk
and webbing technologies and so I try
and do what really motivates me what my
vision for the rest of my life is
finding new ways to think about risks
and sustainable development so we can
create technology solutions to these
challenges we face so my kids getting a
very much the better world than it looks
like we're heading poor and we can do
that by using technologies safeway's
sustainable ways because too that's my
vision will we get there I don't know
there's an awful lot to do we've
actually got to convince people that
they got a single act differently about
risk and technology but I think there's
a chance we might do that so that's my
bitch